riley and
his gorgeous his gorgeous wife gorgeous
wife
how did riley get such a gorgeous woman
like you everyone thinks riley can't get
the beautiful i mean you're a beauty
well thank you howard but right riley i
mean really yeah yeah i mean otherwise
howard miraculous things happen
when you mess with the space cowboy
synchronicity that's what i'm saying but
i have to tell you howard it was um
because of your show that's how you met
riley 96 don't blame us
[Laughter]
how did riley uh court you yeah i mean
it's an amazing story i pursued him did
you were you a believer in what he had
to say about him being uh taken away by
space aliens a lot of people don't
believe you know you believe you
believed oh i did i always did as a
child do you still believe oh yes of
course you do because you couldn't be
married to riley and not by the story
right no i always believed as a child he
doesn't come home at night after all
this and go you know that's that's a
bunch of yeah he's never experienced
uh
robin robin if you if you're keeping up
with current events you know science
channel and all this type of stuff
i wrote this book
better than 25 years ago the coming of
tan yeah the coming of ten and they are
now
revealing a great deal of the things
that i've already written in there even
the concepts and things of this nature
uh as uh and the history
of mankind
uh colluding with extraterrestrials back
down through history all the way back to
ancient jamaica and now they're not
joining us out now but they didn't do
this when i wrote the book right now you
meet him at what point does he propose
okay well you let me can i back up yeah
i want to hear the whole story well it
was in 1996 and i was in it now this is
where a lot of synchronicity comes into
place because you know the coming of tan
i was in a tanning bed in new hope no be
careful with that
no i know
in new hope pennsylvania
and um
the gal before me had your show on right
and i heard his voice
it's a commanding voice well a lot of
people are drawn to his voice but it was
also the subject matter
i heard were you abducted as a child no
no no okay no no no no abduction so you
meet them
and you fight how does she meet him she
hears him on the radio
you start contacting the story gets a
little funnier too because i'd be scared
to contact them yeah i really wouldn't i
was a woman
i thought it was actually his telephone
number it was his publisher's telephone
number
and it turned out he that his publisher
lived like 10 minutes down the road from
me and i said well let me come get the
book but it took me a day and a half to
get through because you guys would he
was they were deluged with telephone
calls to get the book i'm serious that
was back in 1996.
so how did you meet him
well it was very difficult because um
he's a hard guy
yeah oh yeah i pursued him because he
even wrote in his book i can remember
page 313
well you really are in love
maybe you are a little wild it's sad
that no at no point do i give my writing
but those who are meant to meet we
meet me will do so at a given time
connected with him through his publisher
and so please do not try to uh apply me
with copious amounts of sex problems
i haven't even heard her wait a minute
the first time she met him i mean yeah
you heard it
look like
thank you robin did you run out of the
room
[Music]
well
the um the meeting was arranged through
his former publisher and i remember
going to the
where curtis lived
and i saw riley sitting with his staff
and he was looking out at the river and
he stood up and he came over to me and
he hugged me i didn't i know what he
said hugged me no no no it was
a feeling that i have always known him
and when riley had a wonderful feeling
i've ever felt my life like i've i felt
like i i've always known him you're
saying you hugged riley and you fell
like he hugged me
i just felt uh like i've always known
him where i felt like i've known him
when a feeling is that powerful i
imagine it doesn't take long for him to
seduce you yes you never left him once
you no i didn't got that hug oh he
wasn't letting go of her let me tell you
so what it is is true because as riley
points out you're not after his money he
knows you really truly love him
absolutely